I want you to fill this in the whole
story you start selling a little weed
early in high school everybody sold a
little weed of course at what point do
you jump to no I could probably make
some real money or this could be a real
as soon as I found out you could make a
living selling weed that was like like I
was like it's all I want to do well you
didn't think that people were doing that
before no no I I had no idea I thought
you had to be like you know the the
biggest to be the biggest boss the
biggest the biggest boss just to make
any money selling weed I had no idea you
know what I mean because I'm not from
that life how did you find out that that
was a living you knew people that were
doing it yeah it was like a friend's
older brother got you you know or uh my
friend's father he was like a you know
he was like one of these OG guys he was
everything he was a pimp sold cracks old
weed all that [__] he was my first
connect that's like the Costco of crime
he's like doing everything yeah anything
you need he's got it yeah you would
knock on his door he'd be it would be
like 4 P.M and he'd been like a leopard
skid robe you know what I mean he had
the perm and [__] he had like a couple
of [__] and you're like that's what I
want to be I lost my virginity to one of
his hoes yeah I talk about in my book
yeah yeah it was a bad [__] did he
bring it up I wanted to give them money
I wanted to like you know I felt bad
dude well yeah you did oh yeah I did
give them all yeah yeah I wanted to like
tip them this is how hookers work
oh I found out later yeah wait wait wait
are you into the hookers well yeah I
mean when I was a baller yeah of course
come on just easier yeah it's just
easier and it's like I'm living that
life you know I'm in Colombia with like
hundreds of thousands of dollars in my
pockets okay let's go back to the
beginning so when I found out yeah it
was just like his his father was like
yeah this is all I do is like I sell I
basically just sell weed and I pay my
rent and like that was enough for me you
know and you're clearly this is the
interesting thing about it is you have
ambition because you want to do this at
a high level yeah but you just don't
want to have ambition with like a
regular legit job no lazy as [__] it's
laziness yeah yeah okay because now it
seems like you're hustling crazy so the
laziness is gone on yeah it's I've
always been like hard working and
dedicated to something I want to do but
you're like yo these Square jobs seem
absolutely horrible I want nothing I
played ball I thought I was going to
play ball legit or in Europe so I was a
90s white kid who thought he was black
yeah
praise the Andrew
Blackie yeah yeah so no one had to do it
come on come on baby so I was like well
you know how it was like the Camron
album back in the day sports drugs or
entertainment that was it okay there was
no use trying to make money any other
way like I didn't want like because I
grew up middle class I didn't want that
lifestyle at all so dad like hate his
job and you saw it and you're like I'm
not gonna be that way yeah he kind of
did like he was like he was a lawyer and
he was a square and it was miserable all
the time complaining about it kind of
like that cliche you see it in every
movie you know and um yeah I just knew
from a very young age that I didn't want
it and then of course dude watching
movies like paid in full and all that
[__] we we fantasized about all that
dude movies and music do influence you
do yeah yeah
exactly exactly most people don't go off
and do that [__] though yeah you know
what I mean I was just dumb enough to
actually like try to go live that yeah
so so you start out selling you know
nickel and diamond right you don't know
what you're doing you do that for years
it's like comedy you're open my hiking
drug dealing for like five years we
didn't make any real money until like
seven years in the game like I put in my
time put on my ten thousand hours now
real money is give us the example okay
so if you're making a living right it
took about four years to make like a
living where I didn't have to have like
a side job I didn't have to like hustle
other drugs okay because you were
hustling some Coke or whatever exactly
when I was in Eugene Oregon going to the
University of Oregon uh you know
sometimes the weed would dry out meaning
you couldn't get enough Supply right
whatever the connect would get [__] up
so we would go to our Coke guy and we'd
get like a nine piece like nine ounces
maybe get like a half a key move that
get that off or whatever sell some
shrooms so it was kind of like you know
it was whatever it was a Coke money
seductive at all uh yeah the risk is
high but at the same time but you could
take half a block which is nothing and
make crazy and make you know three times
what you make having to sell 30 pounds a
week yeah you know yeah I think I heard
you say in one episode I still if you
want to sell drugs and make money Coke
is still the way to go Coke's still the
way to go he's such a good product and
that's why the fentanyl's [__] it up
it's bad for the coke dealers yeah
you're right it's bad for the brand yeah
yeah so it's like um but back in the day
dude oh it was so like
um you know it still is like it's a drug
that middle class people do
[Music]
um it's viewed as acceptable right and
yes yeah yeah and it was just you know
the hardest part is getting your hands
on good Coke yeah so if you go watch my
show you learn all about how to cut it
up keep them coming back still okay
cutting it up for [__] no no we've
got we would just pull like a two-step
on it a two-step means we would just cut
it up like once or twice very lightly
what do you use use Adderall uh no no
um rookie
so uh no no we put like some B12 in it
and like some caffeine pills so B12 is
just like an energy booster exactly
exactly they don't even know the
difference between getting the Natural
Energy booster the caffeine correct and
you would short them a bit right like I
like just doing that like if I could get
a good price on it it was fire like
chunked up blocked up I don't even waste
it don't even yeah I'll just sell you
less of it but it's fire so you're gonna
come back and most people if they have a
good experience with it they're not
weighing out on a [__] gram scale no
right they trust that they have the coke
they go right back exactly okay so then
how did you have the discipline to not
chase the coke dream because the coke
dream is where the [__] money is uh
yes because I didn't it got so crazy
when you're selling Coke and you have
good Coke especially in a small town
like Eugene your phone is buzzing all
the time all the time I'm in class class
became like a money loss like I'd be in
government
how much time you're going to do
yeah yeah I was in law school
um so I would I'd be in there like and
the and by my burner phone is like
buzzing off the [__] hook and it got
to the point where I'm like I either got
to drop out of school or I gotta like
fall back from selling Coke and just
focus on the weed did something scare
you and that's why you didn't want to do
the coke thing well yeah we're getting
robbed at gunpoint and [__] yeah getting
jokes maybe bring this up this oh sure
sure [__] unreal this is what like
middle class like thugging looks like we
we were we were in a house okay on on
the busiest Street in Eugene Oregon
it's just my friends so they're all in
school too yeah and but they're all
civilians so it's like I didn't I lived
like a double life like they know what
I'm doing I'm the every crew as a dope
man right every crew back then had the D
boy but everybody else was like just
live normal lives you know okay but they
got they bore like the brunt of like the
consequences from being with me so we're
playing Mario Kart for Nintendo 64.
great okay great game fantastic bro and
I'm like killing I'm on like choco
Mountain I'm like beating my time my
record time and we hear a knock at the
door yeah and somebody opens it up and
they go
yo are you here my drug dealing partner
yeah right uh and we're like yeah we
think he's in the back we didn't know
who it was yeah and then we look out for
Mark because people are always coming in
and out of the house it was like a
college house yeah of course and we look
up and there's [__] two digits of ski
masks with the [__] joints on our
face yeah just like run it
imagine that and one of the dudes is
like shaking like these are not Pros
yeah so we were like hey
just take your finger off the trigger
dude we'll go get it for you so you were
cool in the moment everybody was cool I
was so proud of my dudes they were just
like what the [__] but you specifically
did you freak out when you're like this
is it it's over you're like they need to
coke first they're not gonna kill me
immediately no well I knew most of the
work wasn't even in the house did you
pause the game or is that there was the
music going in the best
[Laughter]
okay yo we definitely finished that
[__] after they left
um so but I knew we had a couple pounds
of weed in the house which was like we
can give that up no problem but like the
real money the work with no way I would
keep it in like where you're at of
course not right so I was like I was
like just be cool
not home but I know where it is I'll go
get it for you it's got to give it to
them they [__] bounced out you go
with them to go get it yeah yeah
on my [__] life this whole time he's
in the bathroom taking a [__] he came
out like what's going on guys are you
guys calling me
yeah this guy dude I didn't have any
guns yeah no there's no point there's if
you're really if you're really
yeah exactly dude in Harlem you know you
don't need a gun when you're selling
crack dude what's the matter with you
yeah but it's like but that's also
double the time though so you gotta you
gotta hedge the risk right like you
getting jokes for like that's just a
business expense as long as it's not the
law like we'll give that up you know you
know if you could take him for the whole
trap the whole [__] the whole package
that's on you you're slipping no but the
dudes came in you didn't give them any
pushback and now they can come back
anytime they want to just to keep yeah
yeah but what am I going to do you know
I'm gonna [__] around one of these dudes
and get shot in the head you know it's
not you have to you look at it like like
nothing nothing is worth that you know
and that's the difference between
selling drugs in the ghetto is like
that's true like that will we have kids
to feed and these dudes will kill you
yeah so it's just a whole different it's
a whole different thing so at that point
you have to start going all right if
we're going to scale this up we either
need to partner with some people that
will protect us right or we protect
ourselves that has to go through your
head a little bit no we have to get we
have to move up from all Street sales no
more oh the street sales where it gets
[__] of course of course and and the
the you know because at this point we're
we're selling Coke hand-to-hand and
we're maybe like mid-level dealers for
weed so we're we're sir we're giving it
out to dealers we're the dealers dealer
right but those dudes that robbed us
were working for us we found out later
yeah they were working for us and they
just wanted they were like these dudes
are [__] they ain't got no hard we're
gonna go take it from them it's like
good luck with that and then you're
gonna eat once and then you'll never eat
again yeah exactly yeah I'll starve your
ass you know so it's like that's the
kind of stupidity but we were like Yeah
from here on out like it's got to be
we're only dealing with two or three
dudes right so so if you were so it goes
cartel you at this point were you
getting stuff directly at this point I'm
not dealing with the Cena loans we're
gonna work up to that I'm dealing with
uh I call them the rednecks and so the
best part in the entire country the best
outdoor workout right NorCal in southern
Oregon Southern Oregon is actually you
know and I'm up filming with dudes in
Washington Heights last month yeah and
they were like oh you're from Portland
that's where we used to get our our [__]
that was the best [__]
exactly yeah we're gonna get to that too
yeah yeah yeah
um so we so we were getting it from the
Rednecks picking up maybe 10 10 pounds
at a time right yeah and we're just
selling locally but I'm like if we're
gonna get rich we got to start moving it
across the country yeah that's where the
markup is if UPS had same day shipping
nobody would ever get caught dealing
drugs again well they've sold more drugs
than Chapo Pablo Esco you are well they
they're delivering meth right now
with a smile dude all the time like came
Queens like if that shows
but like it just turned into Breaking
Bad in the middle of it yeah
but James just starts losing weight but
that is the problem is like you you
can't wait two or three business days to
get your [__] we get it the next day
though next day really yeah I'm saying
if you're like uh like you just want a
dime back of course not you're not gonna
wait yeah but there would be no
person-to-person interaction and you
just have to government handle all that
[__] and it's the separation which I
like so I never and I never got caught
with any work they never found me with
any drugs and it's I think it's because
I created that barrier between myself
smart and the the customer